hi my name is Rob Crosley and I know a  little bit about Pokemon in that I've  it's been around me for more than ten  years I know some of the kinda me with  no I'm gonna show you some pictures of  the original hundred fifty you're gonna  tell me what they're called ah this one  is Bulbasaur flower turtle angry token  coconut tree Charmander is how you try  Amanda's custom flight eats Charmander  blue blue turtle  Berenbaum touch that squirtle it's got  guns it's quite oh it's squirtle  squirtle squirtle cave I know what  squirtle is dinosaur elaborate Pikachu  overcompensating rubber purple fire  mouse bag of rocks whack-a-mole  whack-a-mole first draft of Sonic  violent sweet corn marshmallow accident  it's that really a Pokemon messed-up  variety you know what I'm thinking how  do I say this  [Music]  smoke thank you very much Rob you've  made Pokemon a whole different  experience  let's go to dinosaur very good